Caption: welcome welcome to our panel I honestly
Caption: wasn't expecting a full house so this is
Caption: fantastic Welcome to our panel on
Caption: flexible working and inclusive teams
Caption: today we have four very talented
Caption: experienced uh and interesting panelists
Caption: for you today and I I am not going to
Caption: talk too much
Caption: um I am hoping that I can get the
Caption: panelists to intro themselves and and
Caption: we'll have a great discussion you can
Caption: see a QR code sitting there if you have
Caption: any questions or you wish to upvote any
Caption: of the questions that are in our current
Caption: um
Caption: slido moderated panel session you can do
Caption: so via that link
Caption: I am looking at them over here and when
Caption: I have a particular question it will
Caption: come up on the screen okay so this is
Caption: pretty Dynamic overall
Caption: let's have some fun let's have some fun
Caption: okay
Caption: so if you don't know me my name is
Caption: Rebecca Waters I am a software engineer
Caption: now managed people manager at a large
Caption: technology company
Caption: I have here Ryan Oakley hi Ryan how you
Caption: doing I'm good I'm good I'm a software
Caption: developer uh who's new to us I have
Caption: autism I'm currently working on a cloud
Caption: infrastructure team again for a large
Caption: organization and as part of my work and
Caption: in my free time I do neurodiversity
Caption: advocacy where I really focus on the
Caption: strengths they can bring to organization
Caption: so hi Tina thank you for joining us on
Caption: the panel Tina is here as our industry
Caption: expert
Caption: problem what else can you tell us about
Caption: Tina Tina
Caption: hey that was a lot of times you said my
Caption: name there in case you can catch
Caption: everyone
Caption: um so I am Tina I am I'm CEO of a
Caption: company called bellroise which is a
Caption: technology recruitment company I'm
Caption: looking at my two two of my amazing team
Caption: here
Caption: um so we are fortunate enough to work
Caption: with a lot of different businesses in
Caption: hiring diverse teams and helping them
Caption: make sure that they give them inclusive
Caption: environments and in my spare time
Caption: um I am co-chair of women in technology
Caption: wa that's me awesome thank you so much
Caption: for joining us Tina Louise I actually
Caption: work with the Louise and I said to her a
Caption: few weeks ago huh I
Caption: um Louise would you like to do a bit of
Caption: an intro yeah yeah I also work at a
Caption: large
Caption: technology company yeah funnily enough
Caption: um yeah I've obviously been in the
Caption: industry for a long time I've had a lot
Caption: of roles but I've been at tell us for a
Caption: very long time now and have enjoyed
Caption: every minute of it it's the first
Caption: organization where I came out as
Caption: Aboriginal
Caption: um it's a different sort of coming out
Caption: isn't it
Caption: um because I'm obviously not colored
Caption: um it's I was encouraged as a child to
Caption: not identify and so it's it's an inch
Caption: been an interesting journey through that
Caption: while I've been in the organization and
Caption: um yeah
Caption: that's you fantastic and our final
Caption: panelist today is Teresa hi Teresa hello
Caption: how you doing I'm I'm dry a little bit
Caption: nervous now that I'm sitting up here but
Caption: okay
Caption: uh now Teresa what's your field yep so I
Caption: am a user experience designer um I'm the
Caption: senior a senior user experience designer
Caption: at Moodle which is an open source
Caption: learning management system
Caption: and it's a global distributed team I've
Caption: only been there for about a month uh
Caption: prior to that I was a senior user
Caption: experience designer at Bankwest I also
Caption: have two little boys who Factor quite
Caption: heavily into my life as well as a lot of
Caption: different creative Hobbies
Caption: um so another big factor of my life
Caption: fantastic so I'm going to dive into some
Caption: of the questions that are coming up on
Caption: the panel and the first one that I can
Caption: see
Caption: is come on yes uh
Caption: it's okay I've got
Caption: uh an excellent reading voice if you
Caption: inherent or join a team that is not at
Caption: all diverse in terms of gender ethnicity
Caption: Etc what can you do to improve that you
Caption: can't just fire a bunch of people and
Caption: replace them
Caption: so what can you do instead
Caption: I think perhaps
Caption: I I'm looking at everybody here I I know
Caption: we've got a few people in leadership
Caption: positions
Caption: um Louise would you like to to have a
Caption: think about that one yeah I think it's
Caption: actually
Caption: um really an easy thing to think about
Caption: we're all different we're all diverse
Caption: anyway even if you even if your team is
Caption: full of white male middle-aged males
Caption: every one of them will have a different
Caption: background different
Caption: um priorities in their lives and you
Caption: just look for the diversity and you'll
Caption: see it
Caption: yeah that's a fantastic a fantastic
Caption: approach thanks Louise Tina do you have
Caption: some ideas
Caption: it's a it's a tricky one when you
Caption: inherit a team I think um it's it's
Caption: always easier to embed a culture that in
Caption: a team that you build from scratch but I
Caption: think setting the intent of having a
Caption: look around the table I think I agree
Caption: everyone has a different diverse
Caption: thinking and acknowledging that but also
Caption: acknowledging the perspectives that you
Caption: might not have around the table at that
Caption: point you know I think someone's changed
Caption: the phrase from culture fit to culture
Caption: ad and I do really like that sense
Caption: because culture fit is expecting someone
Caption: to fit into your organization culture
Caption: art is respecting what someone can bring
Caption: to the table that you might not already
Caption: have and I think it's having a look at
Caption: that especially in technology because
Caption: you want technology to be fit for
Caption: purpose for
Caption: um the demographic multiple demographic
Caption: you know um that you're targeting
Caption: whether that's your end users or your
Caption: customers or businesses so having
Caption: diverse teams in Tech is really
Caption: important to make sure that Tech fits
Caption: everyone's needs so so you know who
Caption: haven't you got at that table who
Caption: haven't you got as part of that Tech
Caption: Team and make a conscious effort to make
Caption: sure when you are hiring next that you
Caption: are actively looking for people that can
Caption: add to the people you already have I
Caption: think it's a longer process because now
Caption: you can't fire people and you shouldn't
Caption: fire people and because they are
Caption: obviously there on Merit so I think that
Caption: that's really important to
Caption: um State those values and that intent to
Caption: make sure you've got that diverse pool
Caption: around the table and it soon becomes
Caption: clear if you do have people within your
Caption: team that don't buy into that concept
Caption: you'll find that they'll often
Caption: self-select out if they're not
Caption: um on board with going down that Journey
Caption: as well yeah thanks Tina a really
Caption: important Point uh Teresa you work from
Caption: home
Caption: yes yes I do so I have a question here
Caption: and I I do apologize this is not my
Caption: laptop this is Amy's laptop so Amy will
Caption: be coming back in at some point to help
Caption: me sign back in so we're just going to
Caption: uh listen to my voice and enjoy the
Caption: pictures that Windows gives us
Caption: um
Caption: so uh I have a question here if you're
Caption: working from home what's your morning
Caption: routine and do you use any time
Caption: management
Caption: okay so I've been working from home like
Caption: many of us I suppose who are able to on
Caption: and off the past couple of years due to
Caption: covert
Caption: um also as I mentioned I have two young
Caption: children so I took leave I had been
Caption: intending to work from home to some
Caption: extent and my previous employer Bank
Caption: West was very very happy to do that so
Caption: it has been for the past couple of years
Caption: but it was not an official fully remote
Caption: role Moodle is my first uh pretty much
Caption: remote like remote first role
Caption: um so I suppose I'm still kind of
Caption: figuring out the routine now that it
Caption: feels more permanent even though I was
Caption: effectively remote before
Caption: um I imagine it changes for everyone but
Caption: for me personally I end up getting up at
Caption: about six because that's when my kids
Caption: get up
Caption: so the way that it works for me is we
Caption: they watch TV we eat some breakfast then
Caption: my husband looks after them while I go
Caption: get ready
Caption: and then get started I usually try to
Caption: get started fairly early so I can finish
Caption: up early and have a bit more more time
Caption: with them
Caption: um my day when I used to commute into
Caption: the city used to involve a lot more
Caption: getting dressed and thinking about what
Caption: I was going to wear and putting on
Caption: makeup and now I don't really have that
Caption: my my office is in my bedroom so I have
Caption: an extremely short commute
Caption: thank you thank you I I do like that
Caption: small commute I hope that you still
Caption: manage to you know get some some me time
Caption: in that commute a little bit
Caption: um Ryan I was hoping to ask you uh about
Caption: your experiences with inclusive
Caption: workplaces
Caption: okay
Caption: um well I've I was very fortunate to
Caption: find a very inclusive workplace
Caption: um as someone with neurodiversity it
Caption: really comes down to finding a team
Caption: where they're willing to take advantage
Caption: of your strengths and find a workplace
Caption: where they're willing to make
Caption: accommodations so uh once more one is we
Caption: have open plan like most uh companies do
Caption: these days and I can't concentrate very
Caption: well if someone's behind me so I always
Caption: get the desk at the end of the row and
Caption: that may seem like a small thing to some
Caption: people
Caption: but for me that's I would be able to
Caption: concentrate otherwise
Caption: I also as I said have a principal
Caption: engineer who has a deep understanding of
Caption: neurodiversity and he knows what
Caption: projects to put on and where I can
Caption: really Excel so for example I really
Caption: excel at depth and complexity
Caption: thanks Ryan that's a I think fantastic
Caption: to have that support network in your
Caption: workplace right that's a little bit
Caption: about what what Tina was talking about
Caption: there too
Caption: uh the next question is how can you
Caption: overcome the bias from a team that
Caption: predominantly Works nine to five when
Caption: you feel like you're the only one that
Caption: is working flexibly my goodness uh so do
Caption: we have some flexible workers on the
Caption: panel yeah Tina Teresa do you want to
Caption: maybe give us
Caption: some of your thoughts around this
Caption: uh it's it's kind of a tricky one I
Caption: suppose I've been lucky enough to work
Caption: with um managers who have really
Caption: exemplified this and I feel like that's
Caption: that's really important to be
Caption: demonstrating that they they have
Caption: particular boundaries or they need that
Caption: flexibility and they're not afraid to to
Caption: say so it's really important to have
Caption: that then example for the team so you
Caption: can go okay it's all right for me to
Caption: step out for a minute to do something or
Caption: to work in you know a pattern which
Caption: which makes more sense for me as long as
Caption: I'm getting my work done I think it
Caption: requires a lot of
Caption: um a lot of trust
Caption: but uh I find that starting with small
Caption: steps I suppose if you're the only
Caption: person doing it to create that trust to
Caption: show look sure I'm not working a typical
Caption: nine to five but I've taken this small
Caption: step the world hasn't fallen down
Caption: everything is still getting done and
Caption: then you can continue taking those steps
Caption: and then as you're creating that example
Caption: then more people will be able to follow
Caption: yeah yeah I think the example setting is
Caption: a really good point there too razor it
Caption: actually reminds me of my current
Caption: manager who is really vocal about when
Caption: he's taking time out to visit the kids
Caption: or to pick up the kids or to do
Caption: something else and and that's an like a
Caption: value that he portrays to let his team
Caption: know that it is okay that you have a
Caption: life
Caption: we have another question here
Caption: now it feels a little bit similar how
Caption: can we create a flexible and inclusive
Caption: work environment for teams in which some
Caption: team members are required in the office
Caption: at certain times
Caption: uh and others would be able to work from
Caption: home more flexibly
Caption: I am I'm looking at Louise here actually
Caption: because we have some you know in-office
Caption: requirements at our work uh you know
Caption: what are some of the tools that we use
Caption: there to manage that yeah we um have
Caption: people that have have to work on site
Caption: because of the nature of what they're
Caption: working on and the information can't
Caption: leave the site so they can't work from
Caption: home they work in the same team as
Caption: people who don't have that restriction
Caption: at at one or other sort of time so what
Caption: we do is basically
Caption: allow flexibility or
Caption: flexibility at any time and
Caption: just push the boundary of what we call
Caption: flexibility basically so you know if
Caption: they want to if they need to do
Caption: something during the day they go and do
Caption: whatever
Caption: if they want to work whatever hours they
Caption: work whatever hours
Caption: um
Caption: and if they've got an arrangement where
Caption: they normally work from home on say a
Caption: Wednesday but this week they're working
Caption: on classified on information that they
Caption: can't take
Caption: they um will just take that day another
Caption: day hmm
Caption: if they want so it's it's a matter of
Caption: actually actually being flexible not
Caption: just using the words and having a policy
Caption: of being flexible I think there's a
Caption: difference between having a policy of
Caption: flexibility and having contracts that
Caption: people sign up to to be flexible
Caption: um yeah absolutely
Caption: being flexible yeah I like another point
Caption: that you made there as well which was
Caption: about the the team goal and keeping
Caption: everybody is you know everybody is is
Caption: mindful of what that team goal is uh and
Caption: as long as you recognize that overall
Caption: you're achieving that goal together of
Caption: somebody is in the in the office when
Caption: they need to be and and we can manage
Caption: that together that's a that's a really
Caption: good you know mindset to have that
Caption: you're not there alone you're not in
Caption: this alone
Caption: thank you I have another question here
Caption: and thank you for some wonderful
Caption: questions
Caption: um I am trying to keep up with what
Caption: comes at the top so please be aware uh
Caption: bear with me uh this one comes in uh I
Caption: am currently working remotely for a
Caption: non-profit open source startup based in
Caption: Amsterdam
Caption: and I'm the only australia-based
Caption: employee
Caption: how can I recommend or how do you
Caption: recommend I ask to be included given
Caption: everyone else is co-located
Caption: wow
Caption: do you wanna
Caption: I will try that's a big one and it's a
Caption: complex one um and I I will help my
Caption: hands up and say I haven't
Caption: um managed International Teams so
Caption: um but from
Caption: my understanding is what I think the
Caption: first thing you'd need to look at is
Caption: what does inclusion look like for you so
Caption: I think you need to become clearer of
Caption: like what does that look like for some
Caption: because otherwise they'll make
Caption: assumptions and they might put things in
Caption: place that are detrimental inclusion for
Caption: you may be jumping onto a teams chat at
Caption: some point on a Friday to
Caption: um catch up with the team and have a
Caption: quiz night or something for other people
Caption: that might be super cringe and you'd
Caption: hate it so I think being clear about how
Caption: what how you what are the points that
Caption: you need to feel included and then go to
Caption: them and and state what they are like
Caption: and it may be that it's a couple of
Caption: smaller things around
Caption: um
Caption: uh being included on certain chats or
Caption: um asking for information that might be
Caption: a watercolor conversation to be passed
Caption: on you know just think of the things
Caption: that that are important to you and and
Caption: kind of be clear about what they are I
Caption: suppose when you're having those
Caption: conversations yeah
Caption: thank you Tina uh
Caption: is it appropriate for a neurotypical
Caption: straight white man to be pushing for
Caption: diversity and inclusivity within a
Caption: workplace how can we best be allies to
Caption: the cause love it I love it uh now
Caption: none of our panelists are like right in
Caption: that in that area but Ryan
Caption: I am the closest
Caption: um this is actually a conversation I've
Caption: had a lot and
Caption: the answer is of course you can
Caption: um but it's always good to make room for
Caption: lived experience voices
Caption: uh it's also sometimes a part for
Caption: straight white men to start the
Caption: conversation because you can end up in a
Caption: situation where let's say you want to
Caption: make your workplace more accepting of
Caption: disability people where that if people
Caption: with disability or people with
Caption: neurodivergence don't feel comfortable
Caption: standing up so sometimes you need
Caption: someone who's uh for like a better word
Caption: mainstream
Caption: um to stand up and be the voice first
Caption: and once those lived experience voices
Caption: come in then you can start bringing them
Caption: into the conversation and start pulling
Caption: them forward if they want to and feel
Caption: comfortable with it
Caption: thank you that's at an excellent point
Caption: and I love how clear you were able to
Caption: make that point which shows that you are
Caption: a champion to the cause and a great Ally
Caption: uh the next question oh wow they just
Caption: changed so you are dynamically choosing
Caption: what comes up next and we're probably
Caption: one or two questions until the end so
Caption: get those votes in uh how do you balance
Caption: the desire or the need for some staff to
Caption: fully work from home and with the other
Caption: desire and needs of others for
Caption: face-to-face interactions particularly
Caption: for maybe people who feel isolated at
Caption: home
Caption: uh
Caption: in particular in a single cohesive team
Caption: now Tina you spoke on this just a moment
Caption: ago I guess in in terms of how to feel
Caption: included is there anything that you
Caption: would add
Caption: um I'd say that
Caption: um our team are a combination of
Caption: extroverts and introverts I think so um
Caption: there's half of us just love working
Caption: from home and you know we we get drugged
Caption: into the office every now and then the
Caption: other half really missed that connection
Caption: so I think it's it's acknowledging both
Caption: and again being curious about what each
Caption: other needs to feel that connection
Caption: um you know I think a couple of us could
Caption: go two weeks with working with the odd
Caption: check-in and still feel motivated where
Caption: others don't so we've come to the
Caption: conclusion that mostly on a Monday and
Caption: always on a Monday but sometimes on a
Caption: Friday we will all be in the office
Caption: together and that's our personal choice
Caption: and that's what we discussed and worked
Caption: for us as a compromise to have those
Caption: kind of um to accommodate for both the
Caption: extroverts and the introverts across
Caption: team yeah love it
Caption: thank you
Caption: there have recently been experiments
Caption: around the world are of the
Caption: effectiveness of the four day week
Caption: oh this is great do we have many people
Caption: that work part-time with us today
Caption: yeah a fair few a fair few uh do you see
Caption: it taking off in Perth I might go to
Caption: Tina and then maybe Teresa as somebody
Caption: who does work part-time I'm still on the
Caption: fence with it because I can see a lot of
Caption: benefits but also knowing my own
Caption: personality type I just think I would
Caption: kill myself in those four days to still
Caption: get the same stuff done and I'd probably
Caption: need that day just to recover from the
Caption: four days I try to put in so I I don't
Caption: know I for me jewelry is out still I'd
Caption: like to see a lot more evidence of how
Caption: successful in theory and it feels like
Caption: it's going to to work but I can say
Caption: there may be some potential pitfalls
Caption: with it so I I'm I'd like to see a few
Caption: more people experiment with it first
Caption: before and I commit to the team
Caption: Teresa so I've been working four days a
Caption: week since I started at Moodle and I
Caption: love it working part-time is amazing
Caption: um it was kind of helpful to me and that
Caption: I started to do that this as I started a
Caption: new job so I wasn't taking my five-day
Caption: workload and attempting to squish it
Caption: into a four-day workload I was starting
Caption: with an entirely new one so for me that
Caption: that really helped
Caption: um it's a little bit different because
Caption: I'm electing to work four days a week
Caption: it's not a you know the four day work
Caption: week is the idea that you would be paid
Caption: your equivalent salary well that's the
Caption: main flavor of it I suppose but for that
Caption: for that four days
Caption: um and and that is something which I
Caption: assume would probably need a little bit
Caption: more experimentation and a bit more more
Caption: proof to really become more mainstream
Caption: as Tina said yeah
Caption: awesome
Caption: thank you
Caption: the next question is that I find it
Caption: frustrating when leaders come back from
Caption: parental leave and they want to work
Caption: part-time only to be told that the role
Caption: isn't available in this capacity is this
Caption: outdated thinking or can should the
Caption: business be more flexible with
Caption: leadership roles so we have five minutes
Caption: left
Caption: and this is this is a good one so uh we
Caption: have a couple of parents up on the panel
Caption: and Tina you have just come back from
Caption: parental leave I have so I have a
Caption: three-year-old who's in the wonderful
Caption: child care that EDD put on thank you
Caption: very much for that and I have a five
Caption: week old which is a who's at home with
Caption: his dad and I think that that is such an
Caption: outdated concept like completely
Caption: outdated so I went to put my hand up
Caption: when I worked to say I work part-time
Caption: but I'm technically still on Parental
Caption: leave so I'm not sure how that looks
Caption: when I get back yet but
Caption: um for me I'm a leader of two
Caption: organizations so I lead valrose as a CEO
Caption: and I lead women in technology wa as a
Caption: co-chair and they both take up my time
Caption: um I put in a lot of hours but I think
Caption: to say that you can't come back as a
Caption: leader flexibly is I think you're
Caption: thinking more of a manager than a leader
Caption: I think if you're a senior leader um
Caption: it's a perfect opportunity to come back
Caption: as flexibly because it's about being the
Caption: driver of the culture it's about setting
Caption: the strategy it's about trusting your
Caption: team to to kind of execute and do and
Caption: yeah you may need to get in and get in
Caption: and get your hands dirty but if you
Caption: can't like you know I just think that
Caption: it's it's an ideal role sometimes to be
Caption: able to do that and yes it can be high
Caption: pressure
Caption: um but yeah you should at that stage
Caption: have really got a lot more comfortable
Caption: with setting your boundaries with with
Caption: managing your time and being able to do
Caption: that so I think it's an absolutely
Caption: outdated role outdated concept sorry not
Caption: valid
Caption: thank you Tina are there any other
Caption: people who would like to have a go at
Caption: that question overall or shall I move on
Caption: okay so our final question today is how
Caption: can remote teams build strong
Caption: relationships with one another uh Ryan
Caption: do you have uh some remote people in
Caption: your team currently unofficially yes
Caption: so because I work on a cloud team they
Caption: really don't like being in the office
Caption: the main way
Caption: the main way I I see doing it is it's
Caption: good to have a for lack of a better word
Caption: meme culture in teams the other thing is
Caption: you don't need to be in person to have
Caption: coffee
Caption: um so and also if you can get the habit
Caption: of uh
Caption: try and get to the point where you're
Caption: comfortable joking around and battling
Caption: with them within the reasons within
Caption: reason that can really help as well
Caption: yeah awesome
Caption: uh thank you so we do have time for one
Caption: more question and I am just live
Caption: updating because at the moment the
Caption: questions are like my questions which is
Caption: fine
Caption: um
Caption: the the next one that I will ask then is
Caption: is flexible working constrained to time
Caption: or place and how else can workplaces be
Caption: flexible now Louise
Caption: uh I'm going to pick on you here because
Caption: we have quite a you know robust flexible
Caption: working policy and people that do a lot
Caption: of different things so I I know that
Caption: you've got some thoughts on how that can
Caption: work yeah yeah so now we do we have uh
Caption: yes a big big policy it's too big too
Caption: many pages to read
Caption: um and you can have challenge Flex
Caption: time
Caption: whatever I can't remember all of the
Caption: things but I think it's a matter of
Caption: thinking about what it is that makes
Caption: people's lives whole and then ensuring
Caption: that that they get to that chance to to
Caption: do that so using
Caption: um using your policy to to
Caption: take away restrictions from people
Caption: um
Caption: and giving them back a lifestyle so
Caption: um so yeah being able to work outside of
Caption: normal hours being able to
Caption: um you know work
Caption: start work finish work in the middle of
Caption: the day to do something with the kids
Caption: and then start working again later at
Caption: home or whatever you know all these
Caption: things are very helpful for people yeah
Caption: completely I like the idea there where
Caption: you're considering the whole self and
Caption: you know work as part of what we do so
Caption: how can we achieve
Caption: our goals personal and professional
Caption: together just our goals generally and
Caption: what can what our workplaces do as part
Caption: of one of those goals that we want to
Caption: achieve right because we all want to be
Caption: there
Caption: some degree uh
Caption: so so how can we ensure that we all
Caption: actually bring out ourselves yeah
Caption: fantastic
Caption: uh so we are actually out of time would
Caption: you believe that went extremely quickly
Caption: it really did uh can I please ask you to
Caption: warmly thank our panelists
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: if you would like to continue the
Caption: conversation with anyone I'm sure you
Caption: can find them all on the various memes
Caption: or mediums uh memes hopefully not memes
Caption: but maybe I think I've seen a couple of
Caption: gifts already of me moving around on
Caption: stage hopefully no one else so you can
Caption: continue the conversation with our
Caption: panelists at any time and uh and that's
Caption: it enjoy the rest of the day thank you
Caption: so much
Caption: [Applause]